CONNOR McDAVID ALWAYS THE STRRI
EDGES. IT FROM THE RIGHT SIDE
AND KOSKINEN WILL HANG ON FOR
THE FACE OFF.
A SIMPLE PLAY AND DRAISAITL OUT
BOX IS PERLINI,RAPHITE IN THE
ATTEMPT AND REVERSES
DRAISAITL SWINGS IT BACK, ARE
AGGRESSIVE TO THAT TOP SHOT
THEY DO IT COMINGWN TO
THE SIDE OF HIS OWN NET.
DUBOIS, TRIES
-- AND GET THEWAY,
THE OILERS SAY WHATAT
FOREHAND, CENTRES AND MAKES IT'S
WAY OUTSIDE TO CENTRE. STOPS.
>> Kevin: WE TALK ABOUT HIS IQ
INTO A BREAK OUT FOR
SILVER MEDALS FOR PUCKS.
TONINATO FOURTH OF THE YEAR, THE
LAST THIS IS
>>AYED AROUND -- IT STARTS A
TRIED TO PLAY IT BACK DOW TOP
FOR BERRIE AND NUGENT-HOPKINDAV
HELLEBUCYK, HIM AND BACK UP
FOR FOEGELE.
BERRIE G
A COUPLE THE NET
AND BLOCKED BY NATE SCHMIDT.NOW.
PASS, PRESSURED THERE BY HYMAN.
DOWN THROUGH H  IS A GREAT JOB
FROM WHEELER.
LOOK AT THE W
TRYING TO TO WORK IT OUT OF THE
CORNER, TOWARDS THE BLUE